[Musique]
c'est à l'hôtel Akoya que s'est déroulé
quelques jours après son retour sur
l'île la remise du titre d'ambassadeur
d'honneur de la Réunion pour
l'enfantpays Dimitri paayette attribué
par l'IRT ce vice-champion d'Europe est
fier de ce nouveau titre qu'il honorera
tout au long de son parcours le sport a
on a la chance de pouvoir faire passer
des images des images des discours des
valeurs et et voilà ch une fois que que
ça se passe bien pour moi j'essaie de
mettre en valeur mon île de dire que
voilà il y a un petit bout de de caillou
dans le restaurant indien où les gens
sont sont merveilleux et qu'il faut
venir il faut nous découvrir parce queil
y a y a je l' dit notre terre est
remplie de richesse félicitations bravo
avec votre nom bien sûr
dessus au départ il faut savoir que ce
jeune réunonnais a osé franchir les
maires pour aller continuer sa formation
il a bénéficié de la formation à la
Réunion et cette formation il a pour
suiv en métropole il a bonifié en
métropole et à un moment donné le
département l'a accompagné dans ses
efforts parce que pour partir les jeunes
bénéfici de l' du département et
aujourd'hui et bien le symbole qu'on
veut transmettre aujourd'hui c'est de
dire aux jeunes Réunionnais que vous
pouvez vous aussi réussir lui il l'a
fait on en est fier mais combien
d'autres pourrai aussi limité c'est ça
le message en effet le département a
accompagné Dimitri paayette lorsquil
était un espoir dans les années 2000
pour poursuivre sa formation au centre
du Havre en plus de l'aide individuelle
apportée aux jeunes qui sont dans des
centres de formation en métropole le
département aide la Ligue de football
réunionnaise à hauteur de 20000 € pour
son fonctionnement et soutient ses
projets dédiés aux jeunes bah déjà ce
qui ce qu'il ne faut pas perdre c'est
baisser les bras je pense que avec du
travail la négation du sacrifices le
parcours est toujours compliqué personne
arrive arrive à faire une carrière dans
n'importe quel sport sans sans sacrifice
et sans passer par des moments
difficiles mais voilà il faut être bien
entouré moi je voilà j'ai une image de
ma famille c'est très important dans les
moments difficiles et après voilà après
il y a le travail le travail le
seulement c'est ça c'est trava un
travail une force de persévérance et une
réussite qui font la fierté des ré
[Musique]
important c'est reconnaissance pour la
Réunion c'est une reconnaissance aussi
pour ceux qui croient ceux qui sont
déterminés ceux qui sont convaincus dans
l'action
le niveau de dimit est un niveau
exceptionnel mais beaucoup d'espoir et
beaucoup de rêve beaucoup de R de
l'espoir pour la jeunesse sportive mais
aussi un nouvel atout pour lî ce qui est
formidable aujourd'hui on
s'aperçoit que le sport est un véritable
levier pour faire connaître la Réunion
et notamment le touriste et pour moi
c'est une très grande satisfaction
s'aperceoir de
l'utilité pour les jeunes mais aussi
pour la vie économique de
[Musique]
livre